OG Xbox Gamers get to it Morrowind when  it came I think more what did you say x  guys get what what was the term you used  before Xbox game you use the terms oh GX  right so OG meaning like Original  Gangster that you was there from the  beginning so so I remember wait hold on  let me I just I gotta get this all so  we're gonna say that this company that  only developed on PC prior right and had  talked to Xbox since its Inception right  and made a console game for the first  time right and it was exclusive to the  OG Xbox right then Oblivion came out was  exclusive to the 360. we're gonna say  the day with day for the beginning and  that relationship was it was not organic  that's what make sure that  this was it  are